do you like building stuff and being a
general pain in the ass to anyone around
you then Torbjorn maybe for you hey
folks Chris waters here with Mike
McCarty
GameSpot's overwatch hero guide series
continues as we talk about the man the
dwarf the tiny person with the turret
turret is really where you should be
focusing if you're playing Torbjorn I
mean if you're not using your turret
correctly and placing it correctly and
maintaining it your team might kind of
get mad at you because that's your main
focus that's your thing man and the
turret is like another player on the
field or at least it's another asset to
lock down positions to deny access to
lanes to two really hassle the other
team if you played a few matches odds
are you've been shot a few times by a
Torbjorn turret so what are the keys to
good turret placement and management so
I prefer to keep it within distance of
like a payload path or a control zone
and give it like an actual wide vision
cone to be able to shoot in there but
you also want to make sure that it's not
exposed by an every angle try to put it
with a corner behind it or a wall or at
least somewhere you can kind of cover it
if you need to because you're
essentially functioning as a support for
the turret you're repairing it when
people damage it you are upgrading it it
starts more as an annoyance right until
you upgrade it to level 2 you have to
hit it with your hammer five times and
then it becomes more damaging but you
really want to make sure that if people
are chipping away that you're at least
close by or you're ready to put another
one down in a better location yeah and
the wit depth the two threats to your
turret are you know Widowmaker and long
Rin and Farah long range attacks and you
know like a Reaper or a tracer sort of
flanking attacks so if you can minimize
one of those other two flanking angles
or the long-range angles you'll be in a
good place to help your turret survive
now in terms of upgrading let's talk
about that five hits with your hammer
gets it to a level two that's worth
definitely doing when you're setting up
on a point when enemies are not near you
when you're setting up in the beginning
but if your turret goes down in the
middle of a fight put down a new turret
immediately don't waste time trying to
upgrade it because you're gonna do
better damage with your rivet gun
yeah the rivet gun is actually a really
good alternative that you've got the
primary one which is a little bit of an
arc but the shot it does actually expel
is pretty damaging I mean it takes some
skill to use but if you can land them it
does some damage there as far it's got
some bullet drop but again
you can really cause problems the
alternate fire the shotgun is actually
really good up close it's not my
preferred way to play as Torbjorn it can
be a last resort but if you're going up
against the I don't know say like a
tracer it might be a good thing if you
go up against a Reaper I wouldn't
recommend it you're probably gonna get
shredded but it is a very good
alternative but if you land those shots
you're gonna do some really great damage
and I think people sleep on Torbjorn
rivet gun a little bit too much you are
sort of 2 points of fire your turret and
your rivet gun and prowling around the
area is not just good to cover more
areas as Torbjorn but also because you
can collect scrap from any downed player
ally or enemy so that's the thing about
Torbjorn he's not just a defender he's
not just a good off like alternative for
offense he's actually support character
too and it really you want to stay
mobile to get those scrap pieces and
then you can actually throw armor down
to your widow makers who might be
exposed on a high perch or your
Reinhardt's who are covering your team
as you advance he's this mesh of roles
that really plays into a versatile
character buildable those armour packs
can really make a difference especially
for your really low health characters
yours in Yoda's in your Symetra set
cetera but let's talk about Torbjorn
role on offense because he's a natural
fit for defense for sure offense you got
to be a little more situational in terms
of how you can play Torbjorn effectively
yeah if you're quick with getting your
turret down and you can constantly be
putting new ones down maybe above your
group as they advance or even on the
payload there's very specific situations
where you can make use of that if it's a
mobile thing and the payload itself is
inherently immobile when moving platform
that you can take advantage of because
the turret is damaging and if it's
upgraded it can be a weapon on the
offensive and not just hanging back on
defense absolutely especially like you
said if it's on the moving payload or on
moving platforms like on the bull sky
industries map now let's talk about his
ultimate molten core because doesn't
just juice you it juices your turret but
only if your turret is level 2 your
turrets level 1 it's going to be a
little nastier but if it's level 2 it
will go to level 3 and all of a sudden
you'll have this turret that's shooting
rockets and stuff and it's real gnarly
so you want to try to activate that alt
when your turrets level 2 and you don't
have to be anywhere near it either if
you die and respawn and you see that
your turret is firing you can fire that
alt your turret will kick it up a notch
and that can be really crucial in
defending points and on top of that
molten core also gives you a ton of
armor and your turret a ton of armor so
all the sudden you can soak up a ton of
damage
you can really wade into the fray into
the melee and start doing some real mean
work with that shotgun yeah going back
to what you said earlier about being
these two points of fire you are
essentially kind of playing two
characters almost if you want to really
look into it and this makes both of
those points even more powerful you get
shotgun up close is even more powerful
you could almost take out a Reaper if
you're fast enough although I wouldn't
recommend that and if you are accurate
enough with the arc from the primary
fire you can start shredding Reinhardt's
from far away while your turret just
shoots him in the back when you turn to
shields to take you on it's a really
versatile way to amp both your turret
which can be behind people in front of
people and yourself which can also be
behind in front so then it makes two of
these things that people have to worry
about it makes it all the more dangerous
on offense or mainly defense Torbjorn
can be a big threat and a big nuisance
on the fields of overwatch and hopefully
these tips help you be even more of a
problem for your enemies or more
overwatch hero guides subscribe to
GameSpot and stay tuned we've got more
coming
you